miranda devine is a columnist with the
new york post she's watched all this
from the very beginning she's got a phd
in the media business having spent her
life in it and we're happy to have her
join us now miranda thanks so much for
coming on so it does seem to me like the
media once again reporting a story three
years late is trying to get away from
their responsibility for this disaster
you're so right it was crystal clear to
everybody back in early 2020 in iowa and
new hampshire where joe biden was just
woeful he needed to cart around a
teleprompter to the smallest town halls
with the most you know obvious stump
speech that every other candidate could
recite in this in their sleep um i
watched as the sort of you look around
the audience and it just twigged to
people that this guy was not all there
that there was a screw loose uh he was
really the special needs candidate he
was ignored no one showed up to any of
his events uh the it was an open secret
in the media he bottomed out in iowa
number four number five in new hampshire
and one of the the main culprits that
you left out of your very good list of
culprits uh is james clyburn who used
his authority in south carolina among
black voters to swing the vote behind
joe biden and give him the momentum
because the democratic party had just
decided and barack obama as well that
joe biden had to be installed
to beat donald trump because he was the
only one who had a sort of a moderate
image and he had a very carefully
cultivated image that was a myth uh that
he was this unifying force that he was a
an old washington professional a great
foreign affairs expert
and a kind man a family man a decent man
uh you know working class joe and full
of empathy which the country needed
after covert
none of that was true and the problem
for the democratic party was that as
soon as voters pretty much after
afghanistan when joe biden was so
callous so dishonest and so incompetent
the american people saw including biden
voters saw who he really was and i think
once somebody that you have admired and
you know respected looked up to trusted
once you realize that they're none of
those things that they're a liar that
they're possibly corrupt that they they
lack empathy uh then you can never go
back you you recoil and we're seeing
that in polls which are just woeful i
mean uh you know just 29 i think of
democrat voters want joe biden to run
again in 29 and of course the media now
sees that they don't want to be on the
losing side and joe biden is surplus to
requirements now they don't need him uh
they can discard him and they'll be
brutal
this is the cnn presidency and they
should forever live with that stain i
think
miranda vine i appreciate your summation
of that very much
thanks thanks tucker
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight